I sold two of them uh it was a record I  sold and I'll tell you what happened  when I sold this card this is exactly a  mistake I made so I bought these two  hockey cards for 540. 18 months later I  sold those two hockey cards it was a  record-breaking card ever in the history  of hockey I sold the two for 2.2 million  dollars in 18 months okay made nice  money  one of the cars a guy bought six months  later he sold for three and a half  million dollars one of them wow  jeez you should put it up yeah you  should actually show this okay and I  sold it for 1.29 million six months that  he sold for three and a half million  dollars to Wayne Gretzky card so I  missed out on how much money 2.3 million  dollars so oh my god look how much I  missed out right because that was a  non-duplicatable asset one of the guys  that tried to buy my card was Wayne  Gretzky he wanted to buy his own car  because there's only two graded at that  level